Follow lang focus on facebook,
twitter and instagram.
Hello everyone.
Lang focus channel or your up.
I want to talk about something called
code switching.
Gang goal cutie pie article.
Though
some people are monolingual and speak
just one language.
Other people are bilingual or
multilingual and speak more than one
language.
Bilingual or multilingual people
sometimes switch back and forth between
two or more different languages.
This is called code switching.
One situation in which code switching is
common is within immigrant families.
For example,
let's imagine a Russian family moves
from Russia to the United States and the
children grow up speaking Russian as
their native language,
but they learned English outside of the
home.
When the children in that family speak
to their siblings,
they might code switch between Russian
and English.
Another situation in which code
switching is common is in certain
countries where a native language is
spoken alongside a former colonial
language.
One example that comes to mind is in
India where Hindi English code switching
is Coleman and another example is in
Philippines where Tagalog English code
switching is Coleman.
You may have seen my earlier video on
die glossier,
which means switching between two
different languages or two different
forms of a language in different
situations.
For example,
formal versus informal situations.
Code switching is different in that
people switch languages in a single
situation within a single conversation
and sometimes within a single sentence.
Code switching is largely unpredictable
and speakers often impulsively switch
languages without any conscious choice
in code switching one language is the
dominant language.
Normally the native language of the
group,
this is sometimes called the Matrix
language and the additional language is
called the embedded language.
The Matrix language lays out the basis
for the communication and then
utterances from the additional language
are embedded into the matrix language.
There were various reasons that people
might switch from their matrix language
to an embedded language.
Number one,
directive function.
People switch languages to either
include or exclude other people from the
conversation.
Maybe you want to tell secrets,
so you switched to a language that the
people around you don't understand or
maybe the opposite.
Maybe you want to end a private
conversation and reengage with the
people around you,
so you switched to a language that they
do understand.
Number two,
expressive function.
People include the embedded language in
order to express some part of their
identity.
For example,
they want to show their connection to a
certain country or culture,
and in some cases it might be an
expression of status through association
with the prestigious outgroup.
Number three referential function.
Someone who is unable to express an idea
easily in one language switches to the
other language in order to express it
more easily.
This seems to be very common among
bilingual children in immigrant
families.
Number four,
phatic function.
Sometimes a speaker switches languages
or repeat something in both languages in
order to emphasize it.
Number five,
metal linguistic function.
This is reporting something in the other
language or commenting on something said
in the other language.
For example,
you're speaking in Japanese,
but then you quote a lyric from an
English language song without
translating it.
Maybe you'll say something in the
embedded language,
but then you explain it or add further
commentary in the Matrix language.
Number six poetic function.
The speaker says certain words or mixed
jokes in the embedded language for
amusement or for some kind of artistic
purpose.
Code switching takes a few different
forms.
Here are some of the main ones.
Number one inter sentential switching in
which the language switches for entire
sentences or clauses.
For example,
a bilingual Spanish English speaker
says,
sometimes I'll start a sentence in
English.
He tell him,
you know,
and a spaniel.
Number two,
interest sentential switching in which
the speaker switches languages within
the clause or sentence boundaries.
Here's an example from a bilingual
English Portuguese speakers speech.
I don't know,
may you Luca [inaudible] window.
This means I don't know my place in this
world.
Number three extra sentential or tag
switching.
A tag from one language is inserted into
an utterance in another language.
For example,
a bilingual English Japanese speaker
might say it's a good movie.
They show meaning it's a good movie,
right?
Let's look at a couple of cases of code
switching.
The first one is from the Indian movie,
the three idiots.
The Matrix language is Hindi and the
embedded language is English.
The background to this scene is that the
director of a university is welcoming
the incoming freshmen students.
Hi John Lott.
Now let's take a look at the sentence we
just heard the sentence means don't
forget,
I see he receives 400,000
applications a year and of those only
200 are selected you.
The first clause of this sentence,
don't forget it's an English.
This is interesting potential code
switching because the switching occurs
at the clause boundary.
This is probably done to draw attention
to the phrase which is the phatic
function.
Applications is also an English
switching within the clause or sentence
boundaries.
I suspect that this words in English
because it's referring to college
applications and words related to
academic affairs are probably said very
frequently in English select is also an
English.
This is interest sentential switching
again,
the speaker or the script writers
probably chose to say this word in
English in order to emphasize the
importance of this action of selecting
the freshmen students and of course you
as an English.
This is interesting essential because it
occurs at the clause boundary.
This word was probably set apart and set
an English in order to emphasize the
selection of these particular students.
So again,
that's the phatic function in general.
The speaker in this scene might be using
English because he's the director of a
university,
and English is seen as an integral part
of academic life.
Let's look at a second example.
This time from the Filipino movie,
My baby love.
Now,
the background to the scene is that the
young woman's father and the young man's
aunts have started dating each other.
Let's take a look at the whole scene
first.
That long
mopping,
personal libre,
excusing [inaudible] mommy go.
We'll be in [inaudible].
So I'm people in it.
Well,
my smug under,
I'm Mamiko spill my smog under.
I want me to go find him.
And besides,
I always didn't want to [inaudible] if
that's what you wanted to hear,
the good,
at least we have leading something.
I have to go now by now.
I go by
now.
Let's look at a few parts of that scene
again and break them down.
So [inaudible] that month course not
mopping personal and elaborate me.
[inaudible] Mommy Mamiko
can we see interest sentential switching
with English phrases embedded into a
tagalog sentence in her reply,
I think the woman's switches to English
to emphasize certain points.
The main message of a reply that her
mother is beautiful isn't Tagalog,
but this is an emotional conversation.
And the English phrases draw attention
to how she's feeling.
So I don't even give,
if it'll be in suicide,
we're going down one week or so.
I'm people in it.
Well,
my smog and dot Emami go
here.
We see extra sentential switching or tag
switching the interjection,
well as an English,
but the rest of the sentences.